thank you
[Music]
so the NASDAQ has just hit a 13-month
high school fan of the NASDAQ yeah yeah
what do you like on it six acronym stuff
gets me off yeah
what does it even dance stand for
[Laughter]
please pick a letter National
Association of stocks and
Securities dealers automated quotations
automated quotations
so they automate this [__] National
Association of security [__] up they
[__] automated it sounded like a joke
I thought you made that up
I already said automated Queen
right there
they'll even say that you
Steve Dylan yeah we don't use Sports
comedy we've seen nothing
okay so check this out
how do you feel about the economy right
now you think it's pretty tight way
tight
next on hip hop news is as tight as your
wife was when you have first met her or
lately
great
no check this out right so yeah
unemployment just posted uh usually the
the uh the amount that unemployment
Rises is very slow however the increase
in the unemployment rate is much worse
than anticipated usually you raise about
half a point from the lowest
unemployment rate which means the
economy is going into recession we just
Rose three tenths in a month what do you
think about that [__] that's not what
Kamala said but that's the
counterbalance to what I mean that we're
that we're like rapidly going into a
recession unemployment just went up by a
lot well an unusual Spike while we see
this kind of positive news from NASDAQ
yeah so what are we what are we seeing
what's going on what's up with
unemployment
so stocks are going up but
General well-being of people yeah it
sounds like what happened during Cove
it's happening again we have a lot of
crazy [__] happening like that like our
interest rates are Sky High and our
housing prices isn't really dropping
either wow like we're not seeing the 30
that we saw in 2008. you're expecting
that so there's a lot of like this Push
Pull like simultaneous [__] that's going
on it just sounds like like you always
say the personal interest of the elite
is being fulfilled
so what does that mean is that what is
that is it like that's the strange part
right so that's what we're experiencing
yeah and what does it mean yeah during
covet that this happened this very same
exact thing it was like okay cool well
all of these interest rates are are
still down they're printing money like
crazy is it because there's not enough
jobs or is it because people are not
working and collecting unemployment like
it's all the tech jobs everyone's
getting cut like yeah I'm right uh so
that's shifting things but what tech
jobs are going on or do tech stocks are
going on yeah I feel like everywhere
that I know like my buddies that have
small businesses they have a hard time
hiring people or keeping people on their
staff our text is Tech talk um Tech
stock going up because they're saving on
employee costs it could be they're
actually cutting costs yeah if they
don't need they're actually starting to
make money now yeah
like like and everyone was predicting
that Twitter was about to be not
workable by Monday did you did you hear
how it got downsized a little bit more
recently no man because uh they were
gonna post that what is a woman
documentary on Twitter and they found
out there were more employees that were
trying to suppress it that's right
someone just got fired today yeah yeah
and they fired them today he found out
who it was
wow remember that dock that you were
talking about what is a Woman by Matt
Walsh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah on Twitter
for free
the one that you were
you were remade
I wish I had that idea
not far from the truth but yeah
oh Joe's the best you can't rock this
book
he's so buoyant he's Untouchable man it
comes right back up dude let's see tips
over
but this is kind of an unusual
correlation right unemployment High
NASDAQ High what's the story you're
connected
I don't know Hello Kitty I can't call
hello
that's a guy that actually does provide
a lot of jobs for people you're saying
it's hard to get people to like work
it's hard to get people working no one's
working in this field yep
you're fighting against you know
competitors there's there's jobs though
like there's so many you know shops that
need help
um but I think it's the the entry-level
jobs so like high school college
traditional jobs that like People's
First jobs
a lot of those places are open but like
a lot of workers are not working raise
wages dude
just raise the freaking wages
yeah I raise everything up
dude it's the best prices
dude I'm on Reddit and I'm yelling at
you just raise them wages up yeah why
aren't you doing it
should we try to get it it doesn't get
it doesn't work because what is it is it
like the unemployment and you got to
move up the prices of your whole menu
and then stick a shot and less people
come in gotta cut people again
um
don't you live in a nice house you
should probably downsize that sell a
week there was this one I forgot which
casino it was um but they were missing
servers and they put out six-figure
contract to be a server and they still
can fulfill their quotas
yeah nobody wants to do that it's crazy
six figure contracts over there gears
that's why Texas Station crushed it's
crazy a server at a casino yeah
dude Nick Dunn's [__] ready to go I'm
ready to go baby six figure guaranteed
for six figs yeah six figs would you
want baked potato would you want french
fries
ain't good at that that's that Resorts
World you barely have to work yeah yes
nobody's there you want the unlimited
Subway combo
again yeah it was crazy
we packed them Meats high and deep we
pack them up but people just don't want
to work right now do you think what so
[__] what are these young kids doing
then are they just like starting Drop
Shipping businesses or something I think
everyone's doing like all of them you're
like dude that's like the [__] racket
I see everyone like dude here's how to
start your Drop Shipping business like
it's pretty smart they're working for a
team I've seen the craziest incentives
like fast food chains offering benefits
like [__] Wendy's offering sign-in
bonus like the stuff that you've never
never here forever Burger King says you
can be the [__] King
yeah I should be the king now Taco has
really great benefits too they can't get
people worked there either yeah now what
is it I don't know man you want to work
those jobs what's King Taco benefits I
don't know how much green sauces you
like yeah you think people you can't
post on Instagram something delicious
like that you know they're saying like
chinatowns too or like these ethnic like
immigrant businesses they all don't
survive many generations because like
let's say like the first wave of
immigrants they build the restaurant
right and it becomes like a HomeTown
favorite but they send their kids off to
become doctors or whatever and the kids
don't want to run it that's true so then
like it kind of dies after one
generation and you miss that food of the
community but it's like gone from there
claims but then they don't do anything
about it yeah right what happened to
Fuddruckers dude yeah yeah really how's
my people's Foods
bro anytime I go to Mendocino Farms
because you know it's popular yeah
here okay the one that passes the one
that I go to in Pasadena is it even good
dude no it's not about that it's not
about that but it's so true
it's very popular
bro okay so whenever you go to Mendocino
Farms there's a gang of like old Chinese
aunties uncles yeah and like immigrants
right like Middle Eastern immigrants
like all kind of random folks all right
and they're all waiting to do food
delivery really bro I'm telling you like
they have that whole Casino their
catering is like on point of how they
deliver it oh dude really everything
there there no one's touching them
everything
are they just like waiting on ubereats
and [__] or doordash they're waiting
nobody's touching them I gotta pay 45
for two sandwiches how they present
everything's presented and delivered and
it's just it's just very reliable the
system's really good get the sandwich
study to eat but like
I've never bought anything there before
it's pretty solid salads are actually
their salads are amazing salads are
solid I never been to a uh erwan I want
to check that out oh 30 smoothies yeah
dude oh three dollars three dollars
gonna eat my dick you gotta pay a cover
fee before you walk and I bet you they
have a worker shortage too [__] that nah
that's like pressed coffee get the [__]
out of here or drip coffee yeah sorry
sir it's gonna be another 45 minutes
this week
it's because it's dripping one [__]
drop out of time
but it's gonna be really good it's gonna
be piping hot what do you think that I
came here two hours early
oh I'm so relieved
yeah I wish I knew what was happening
because it's like obviously there's a
lot of jobs open but people don't aren't
are they're like not looking for a job
so maybe they don't need money and then
so
I don't really know what's going on
because they're saying like usually when
there's unemployment like the last
recession and all that it's because
there were no jobs
but now there's like there's a lot of
companies at all levels looking for
workers but no one's no one's coming
into work so how's all these people
surviving that's the that's the thing
Drop Shipping who knows well they said
credit card or uh um
car loans car loans insane yeah all the
time oh we're [__] oh my goodness
printed four trillion more dollars oh
[__] okay so it's a good time to be a
Repo Company then
maybe or a pawn shop
maybe we'll take a business to start
Pawn Stars oh yeah
it's really good yeah